when a person is smoking cannabis one of
the plant's chemicals known as THC
passes from the lungs into the
bloodstream the THC is then carried by
the blood to the brain where it acts on
specific cannabinoid receptors
these receptors are found in areas of
the brain associated with concentration
thinking time perception coordination
memory and sensory pleasures
the effects of THC activation in these
areas is responsible for the high that
people feel but besides creating an
altered state of mind something else
happens
[Music]
in the United States according to a 2018
survey one in eight adolescents aged 12
to 17 consumed marijuana in the past
year in 12th grade about 1 in 16 do so
daily so what's the problem even super
smart people smoke right let's look at
the effective cannabis on a teenager's
brain
the brain's response to counter the
effects of THC impairs its attention its
ability to remember and its potential
for learning these effects can last up
to several days this would not be such a
problem if our brain ran like a machine
but that's not the case
the brain is a living organism maybe the
most precious one there is in teenagers
that organism is still immature it takes
about 25 years for the human brain to be
fully developed this is why when
teenagers and adults argue they often
come to different conclusions there is a
biological reason for that
adults have a fully developed prefrontal
cortex the part of a brain that is
responsible for judgment and an
awareness of long-term consequences the
cortex of teenagers is still growing
they are more influenced by their
already matured limbic system which
responds to fears and emotions
[Laughter]
if the developing brain is exposed to a
lot of THC the part responsible for
controlling emotions may never reach its
full potential this can have long-term
consequences and effects on one's
measurable intelligence learning and
judgment
one study that followed 13 year olds for
25 years has found that those who
regularly consume marijuana lose on
average 5.8 IQ points by the time they
reach adulthood since our average IQ is
just 100 that is enough to shut the door
to a good college or close the
opportunity to work at a great company
but that's not all
there is also evidence that some
teenagers that use cannabis are at
higher risk of developing depression or
even a psychosis a psychosis changes the
way the brain processes information and
causes you to lose touch with reality
you can see and hear things that aren't
real and may completely lose your mind
in short the high of cannabis comes with
a multitude of side effects some might
be fun some might be healing and some
are potentially horrible we don't always
know
if you want to live life with the
ultimate learning machine inside your
head you might want to wait until your
mind is fully developed before trying
weed
what are your thoughts did you ever try
cannabis as a teenager and if so do you
think it did damage to your mind or not
please share your experiences in the
comments below
foreign
this video was made in association with
cannabis.org and was sponsored by
weed.com
if you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation you
can support us visit patreon.com Sprouts
take a look learn how it works and
what's in it for you we hope to see you
there
if you are a parent or educator check
out our website
sproutschools.com there you can find all
our video lessons for download without
background music plus additional
resources and classroom activities